[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sport
einen schirm und so von mir kein chaos
auf den bahnsteigen offenbar haben sich
die bahnkunden auf die vielen
zugausfälle eingestellt
runde drei im bahn streikt die gdl setzt
ihren arbeitskampf fort trotz eines
neuen angebots der bahn will den streik
vor gericht stoppen
ausnahmezustand in new york in nur einer
stunde fällt so viel regen wie noch nie
straßen- und u-bahnen werden überflutet
mehrere menschen kommen ums leben
und zwei medaillen auf einen streich die
deutschen drei radfahrerinnen feiern am
vorletzten wettkampftag einen
doppelerfolg
[Musik]
bahnfahren macht derzeit keine freude
dieser dritte und längste streik zwingt
die kunden wieder zu enorme flexibilität
während der tarifkonflikt zwischen bahn
und der gewerkschaft deutscher lokführer
zunehmend eskaliert das gestern
vorgelegte neue angebot der bahn sei
vergiftet sagt die gdl jetzt versucht
die bahn mit einem eilantrag den streik
per gericht zu stoppen oliver deuker
leere bahnsteige bundesweit wie hier in
hannover nur wenige verbindungen laufen
planmäßig rund 60 prozent der züge im
regionalverkehr fallen aus im
fernverkehr fährt nur jeder vierte zug
obwohl die bahn einen notfallplan
aufgestellt hat
festgefahren die tarifverhandlungen das
gestrige angebot der bahn lehnte der
chef der lokführergewerkschaft gdl als
unzureichend ab der arbeitskampf ist
notwendig weil die arbeitgeber seite
seit monaten trickst und täuscht sie
wissen sie haben angebote gemacht die
keine sind unter anderem fordert die gdl
in diesem jahr 1,4 prozent mehr gehalt
2022 noch einmal 1,8 prozent insgesamt
also 3,2 prozent das bietet auch die
bahn allerdings erst ab 2022 und bei den
laufzeiten die gdl und bahn weit
auseinander zusätzlich bietet die bahn
bis zu 600 euro corona prämie an will
statt streiks endlich verhandeln
deswegen fordere ich die gdl-spitze auf
die blockadehaltung endlich aufzugeben
und die tarifpartner es sich gehört an
dem tisch zu kommen mit uns zu
verhandeln das ist mögliche zu lösungen
zu kommen die deutsche bahn lässt nun
per eilantrag die rechtmäßigkeit des
streiks überprüfen verbot einer stunde
begann vor dem arbeitsgericht frankfurt
die verhandlung
ging es in diesem streit nur um
laufzeiten und die höhe der
einmalzahlung dann wäre die einigung
vermutlich längst gelungen doch es geht
um mehr die vergleichsweise kleine
lokführergewerkschaft sieht sich in
ihrer existenz bedroht hans-jürgen viel
über die hintergründe dieses bahnstreiks
zum dritten mal gdl-streik und das
obwohl die bahn gestern noch ein
verbessertes angebot vorgelegt hatte die
lokführergewerkschaft zeigt sich
kompromisslos es gibt der gdl auch darum
sich gegenüber der größeren eisenbahn
und verkehrsgewerkschaft evg zu
profilieren bei der bahn gilt seit
januar das tarifeinheit gesetz wonach
nur tarifverträge der mehrheits
gewerkschaft mit mehr mitgliedern im
jeweiligen betriebs teil zur anwendung
kommen das könnte die harte haltung der
gdl befördert haben so experten
mehrheits gewerkschaft wird man aber
nicht indem man brav ist in dem man
zuhört sondern neben dem man selbst
initiative beweist in dem man
aufmerksamkeit erzeugt konflikte eingeht
und in diesem sinne dann deutlich macht
dass man eigentlich die bessere die
echte hre die authentischere
gewerkschaft ist die nämlich mehr raus
holt für die beschäftigten und damit
auch die existenzberechtigung hat als
größere gewerkschaft in die nächste
runde zu gehen so kämpft die gdl um ihre
bedeutung im bahn konzern will
erklärtermaßen wachsen und neue
berufsgruppen erschließen war sie bisher
nur für das fahrende bahn personal
zuständig für alle anderen berufe die
evg sowie die gdl diesmal und künftig
auch fahrdienstleiter berufs und
werkstattpersonal rangierer und
gleisbauer vertreten auch dafür kämpft
sie mit harten bandagen
der einsatz in afghanistan hat es der eu
noch mal deutlich vor augen geführt ihre
militärische abhängigkeit von den
amerikanern die europäischen regierungen
konnten nicht einmal den flughafen in
kabul ohne us soldaten schützen als
lehre daraus wird jetzt über eine
schnelle eu eingreiftruppe diskutiert
anne gellinek
tag drei nach dem abzug der amerikaner
aus afghanistan der flughafen kabul
liegt still ob und wann er wieder
geöffnet wird ist ungewiss es sind diese
bilder eines geschwächten westens die
beim treffen der europäischen
verteidigungsminister in slowenien eine
neue diskussion darüber anfachen ob die
eu eine schnelle eingreiftruppe braucht
ja sagen einige mitgliedstaaten allen
voran frankreich mindestens 5000 männer
und frauen aus europäischen armeen die
gemeinsam üben und unter gemeinsamen
kommando stehen würden die deutsche
verteidigungsministerin eher
zurückhaltend worüber wir reden müssen
ist die frage sind unsere prozesse
darauf abgestellt könnten wir schnell
entscheidungen treffen sind wir genügend
eingeübt haben wir das richtige
equipment bislang lautet die antwort auf
jede dieser fragen nein schon vor über
zehn jahren wurden so genannte
europäische battlegroups kampftruppen
ins leben gerufen doch niemals
eingesetzt die europäer stritten jedes
mal über sinn und zweck einer möglichen
mission der lettische
verteidigungsminister kritisiert deshalb
manchen mitgliedstaaten fehle der wille
militär auch einzusetzen
länder wie deutschland zum beispiel die
müssen ihre bürger überzeugen dass sich
die welt verändert hat allein mit guten
worten kann man leute wie die taliban
nicht überzeugen kramp-karrenbauer
versucht den kompromiss eine koalition
der willigen könne voran gehen und
beispielsweise spezialkräfte künftig
gemeinsam europäisch trainieren die eu
will nicht länger ein militärischer
zwerg sein da sind sich alle einig doch
sobald es konkret wird droht streit wer
würde eine eu eingreiftruppe
kommandieren wo würde sie eingesetzt und
was würde das kosten solange diese
fragen nicht beantwortet sind bleibt ein
europäischer kampfverband was es ist ein
phantom
unterdessen heißt es von den taliban sie
würden in kürze ihre neue regierung
vorstellen möglicherweise morgen für
eine regierungsbeteiligung von frauen
und überhaupt für frauenrechte sind in
der westlichen provinz herat knapp 50
afghanen auf die straße gegangen viele
frauen namen aus angst nicht an der
kundgebung teil
jetzt zur corona lage in deutschland bei
der aktuellen vierten welle fällt auf
dass sie vor allem kinder und
jugendliche trifft unter 12-jährige
können noch nicht geimpft werden aber
bei den älteren versuchen die
bundesländer jetzt tempo zu machen
bislang sind bei den 12 bis 17 jährigen
bundesweit fast 22 prozent vollständig
geimpft knapp 33 prozent haben
mindestens eine spritze bekommen wie
niedersachsen die impfquote bei den
jugendlichen steigern will zeigt
elisabeth schmidt
statt rummel in braunschweig neben dem
karussell und der pommesbude geht's zum
peaks die korona impfung bekommen
jugendliche ab zwölf jahren hier ohne
termin und das kommt gut an
je schneller umso besser es gibt
bestimmt ein zwei sachen somit läden
oder so den vorteil laufen kann test
machen wir haben auch eigentlich ein
zweiter termin im zentrum gekommen war
dass es noch lange hin und haben wir
gesagt haben wir schon mal eine woche
früher
niederschwellig und bürgernah die sonder
infektion gibt es diese woche an mehr
als 50 orten in niedersachsen die
landesregierung drückt aufs tempo denn
die sieben tage inzidenz bei
jugendlichen steigt bundesweit
vergangener woche lag sie bei gut 184
mehr als doppelt so hoch wie in der
übrigen bevölkerung mit dem schulstart
in niedersachsen heute kommen strenge
regeln wieder masken pflicht im
unterricht diesmal auch in grundschulen
schülerinnen und schüler mit einem
impfnachweis haben vorteile die die
geimpft sind müssen sich nicht testen
wenn nicht geimpftes muss sich testen
das ist der unterschied aber ansonsten
ist ganz klar der zugang zu bildung der
wird nicht an der frage abhängen bin ich
geimpft oder nicht massenweise
quarantäne und schulschließungen
vermeiden dass es das ziel kinder und
jugendärzte warnen dennoch vor einem
impfstoff schülerinnen und schüler
ausgeübt werde sie zählen aber auch
vorteile der impfung auf wir verändern
bei kindern und jugendlichen die zwar
selten aber doch vorkommenden schweren
verläufe wir wissen noch wenig über long
cockpit und der zweite grund ist
natürlich auch dass wir
eine erden immunität schaffen
zumindestens deren immunität verbessern
endlich wieder freiheiten genießen für
viele jugendliche ist die impfung ein
schritt richtung normalität
und hier noch die aktuellen corona
zahlen das robert koch institut meldet
13 1715 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind
1089 mehr als vor einer woche die sieben
tage incidents steigt auf 76,9
374 corona infizierte kamen innerhalb
eines tages neu ins krankenhaus die
sieben tage incidents hier 1,74
diese sogenannten hospitalisierung
zahlen zeigen allerdings nur einen trend
weil die meldungen zum teil verzögert
sind
wer noch nicht genau weiß wo er in gut
drei wochen bei der bundestagswahl so
ein kreuz setzen mag dem bietet seit
heute wieder der wahlomat
entscheidungshilfe mit dem online
angebot der bundeszentrale für
politische bildung können wählerinnen
und wähler herausfinden welche parteien
und positionen der eigenen haltung am
nächsten sind neu ist diesmal unter
anderem dass positionen aller parteien
direkt miteinander verglichen werden
können
38 thesen zu verschiedenen
politikfeldern wenn sie lust haben den
wahlomat auszuprobieren schauen sie in
die zdf heute app dort können sie das
programm anklicken ist immer wieder
interessant
der europäische gerichtshof hat
deutschland aufgefordert der
bundesnetzagentur mehr unabhängigkeit
einzuräumen die agentur ist für die
regulierung der energie- und
kommunikationsnetze zuständig die
richter betonten dass die regulierer
unparteiisch und ohne politische
vorgaben handeln sollten bisher sind sie
direkt im
bundeswirtschaftsministerium unterstellt
in nordrhein westfalen heute gleich
mehrere razzien gegen rockerkriminalität
im fokus der polizei
personen die mit den hells angels in
verbindung stehen zwei verdächtige
wurden festgenommen sie stehen im
verdacht an mehreren mord film 2013 und
2014 beteiligt gewesen zu sein
schauen wir in die usa rücken einer
hatte im süden milliardenschäden
angerichtet nun haben seine ausläufer
auch an der ostküste gewütet in der
millionenmetropole new york fiel so viel
regen wie noch nie zuvor dort starben
mindestens acht menschen in überfluteten
kellern die behörden riefen den notstand
aus claudia bates berichtet
die autos treiben im wasser es war ein
solcher sturzregen nach wenigen minuten
waren die straßen überflutet die
feuerwehr holte menschen aus ihren autos
kurz bevor ein fahrverbot verhängt wurde
für die ganze nacht ein wasserfall in
der u-bahn viele saßen in den waggons
fest als der verkehr wenig später
komplett eingestellt wurde in einigen
stadtteilen mussten die menschen mit
schlauchbooten aus ihren häusern geholt
werden die nun unbewohnbar sind
beim letzten sturm konnten wir uns
vorbereiten dieser jetzt kam unerwartet
ich habe jetzt nichts mehr auch kein
dach über dem kopf aber wir werden uns
zusammentun und eine lösung finden
im ganzen nordosten tobten stürme
tornados ließen kleine ortschaften als
trümmerhaufen unter sich wie hier in new
jersey
nur fünf minuten und alles war kaputt
regen und stürme sind vorbei aber große
flächen sind überflutet noch zur stunde
müssen menschen aus ihren häusern
gerettet werden präsident biden hat
großzügige hilfe der regierung zugesagt
griechenland trauert um einen seiner
helden
mikis theodorakis sein berühmtestes lied
kennen sie alle
[Musik]
ob als komponist dirigent oder als
politischer aktivist theodorakis galt
und gilt als stimme seines landes er
wurde 96 jahre alt heute haben wir ein
stück der griechischen seele verloren
sagte kultusministerin andreas postel
erinnert
nur diese zwei töne braucht mickys wie
in die griechen liebevoll nennen umwelt
ruhm zu erlangen seine komposition zu
diesem merkwürdig improvisierten sirtaki
den anthony quinn als alexis sorbas
tanzt wie ein stein hingen diese melodie
am bein hat er einmal gesagt der
natürlich nie auf diese zwei töne
reduziert werden wollte sein leben
selbst war eine sinfonie geboren am 29
juli 1925 auf der insel kosmetischen
mehr fällt er früh durch seine
außergewöhnliche musikalische begabung
auf leben und werk gehören bei
theodorakis eng zusammen seine biografie
geprägt vom widerstand gegen die
faschistischen besatzungstruppen im
zweiten weltkrieg dem anschließenden
bürgerkrieg und der griechischen
militärdiktatur
das komponieren war für mich ein ausweg
so wie ein gestrandeter im glauben an
seine rettung eine flaschenpost ins meer
wirft sagt er einmal über sich
der dax war als damals bekennender
linker auch in der ddr populär mehrere
seiner werke werden im osten
deutschlands uraufgeführt
jetzt am ende meines lebens kann ich
sagen dass ich genau das gemacht habe
was ich machen wollte ich will mich
nicht rechtfertigen nicht sagen ich gehe
so weit wie die umstände es mir
erlaubten nein ich ging so weit ich eben
konnte weiter ging es nicht
in seiner heimat heißt es mix habe die
griechische seele in die sprache der
musik übersetzen können mit einer
dreitägigen staatstrauer nimmt das land
nun abschied von der stimme
griechenlands
[Musik]
in frankfurt am main hat der bau der
jüdischen akademie begonnen beim
spatenstich dabei der präsident des
zentralrats der juden in deutschland
josef schuster und hessens
ministerpräsident volker bouffier in der
akademie soll es in seminaren und
vorträgen um jüdische perspektiven zur
politik philosophie und kultur gehen
und so wird das ganze mal aussehen
2024 soll hier der betrieb starten
und jetzt zur heutigen paralympics
bilanz norbert drei medaillen für das
deutsche team und da waren die
radsportlerinnen wieder besonders
erfolgreich im straßenrennen gab es gold
für jana juhnke und silber für angelika
drei okay sei für beide athletinnen
schon der zweite medaillengewinn in
tokio
die bedingungen für ihn nicht ideal
aber
klar die weiter gehe ich gerne wissen
korrigiert das für minimale ziel gold
mit 818 erreicht blieb aber damit unter
der angestrebten weite des
olympiasiegers tinto clou von 841
schmälert aber nicht seine
internationale vormachtstellung
daraus ja das war aus versehen ein
bericht von gestern leider knapp daneben
aber auf jeden fall vorbei apropos ganz
knapp an gold vorbei dagegen thomas
brüchle und thomas mit berger im finale
des teamwettbewerbs verlor das deutsche
tischtennis duo gegen den dauer-rivalen
china die goldmedaille dabei nach dem
doppel zum greifen nahe im fünften satz
der matchball von schmidberger und
brüche zum 11 zu 9 die führung in ihrem
bereits dritten endspiel im
teamwettbewerb der paralympics
dann die beiden einzel ein sieg hätte
gereicht doch brüchle verlor gegen feng
das entscheidende duell schmidberger
gegenteil der deutsche startete gut ging
sogar mit 2 0 in führung doch die nerven
stark schlägt schmidberger mit drei zu
zwei für die deutschen im dritten duell
wieder gold verloren statt silber
gewonnen die enttäuschung riesig
die enttäuschung auch bei den deutschen
rollstuhl basketballerinnen ihre
siegesserie ist gerissen auf ihrer
mission gold bei den paralympics
scheiterten sie im halbfinale an den
niederlanden gegen die europa- und
weltmeisterin und stand es am ende 42 zu
52 das deutsche team spielt am samstag
gegen die usa um bronze
und das war's vom sport etwas verkürzen
fehler passieren immer wieder
großer moment jetzt für alle abba fans
in diesen minuten kehrt auf youtube die
schwedische kultband nach 40 jahren mit
virtueller hilfe ins rampenlicht zurück
agnetha björn benny und anni-frid mit
neuen songs sogar einem ganzen album
[Musik]
dieses comeback ankommt wird sich zeigen
immer wieder schön das wetter kommt gut
an der warmen spätsommer bleibt uns auch
in den nächsten tagen erhalten ob das
überall sonne bedeutet erklärt gleich
katja horneffer das heute journal um
21.45 mit marietta slomka danke für ihr
interesse machen sie sich noch einen
schönen abend und bis morgen wenn sie
mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
und auch heute morgen hatten wir wieder
einige nebelfelder zum beispiel am
oberrhein aber auch an der mosel
deutlich hartnäckiger hielt sich diese
hochnebeldecke in norddeutschland aber
sonnenschein wärme und wind sorgten dann
doch dafür dass der hochnebel immer mehr
verschwand und sich nur noch ganz
örtlich halten konnte heute in der nacht
gibt es wieder neue nebel und dunst
felder sonst aber es ist doch häufig
klar und die temperaturen sinken auf
werte zwischen 13 grad an der
nordseeküste und bis 7 grad am alpenrand
und morgen liegen die werte dann an den
küsten sogar 18 19 sonst meist bei 21
bis 24 grad und hier in franken oder
auch am rhein gc 25 26 grad rauf und
morgen wird das ein sehr sonniger
freitag höchstens in norddeutschland
sind die wolkenfelder mal etwas dichters
ist dann wieder so eine hochnebeldecke
aber sonst ist es einfach nur sonnig und
ganz ähnlich geht es dann auch über das
wochenende weiter wohl bis weit in die
nächste woche hinein am wochenende
liegen die temperaturen meist bei 18 bis
27 grad gute nacht